it's always sad when someone dies huh
this young man was driving drunk ,
without knowing how to do it properly
okay let me say that again this young
man was driving drunk without having
practiced so he would know how to do it
right now you're not stupid and I'm not
gonna treat you like you are I'm gonna
tell you something that's pretty
controversial some people drive better
when they're intoxicated than they do
when they're sober hi my name is deputy
Johnson I'm able to do such a thing all
right think about it my day to day life
when I'm driving what am i doing I'm
playing air guitar maybe I'm trying to
wipe mustard off my pants or I'm texting
somebody but I'm sure as hell not
looking at the road yes I said hell live
with it when I am driving drunk 2
o'clock 10 o'clock Mirror Mirror every
30 seconds the air conditioners on me
I've got some speed metal on the radio
I'm pumped I'm paying attention believe
me I've been doing this since I was 11
years old
I'm very good at it it's like using
condoms or popping up penicillin before
you have multiple encounters you know
safety yeah see a lot of pretty girls
here today a lot of pretty girls some of
you have definitely got careers in
gentlemen's magazines later on an adult
entertaining all right I hope that when
it comes time to list your turn-offs
that vehicular manslaughter will be one
of those turn offs